Okay, the correct answer here is the normal
CCR5 allele is dominant. Because all you need is
one allele to produce normal CCR5 protein that can
reside on the surface of T cells and allow
HIV infection. Thus masking the effect of this CCR5
delta 32 allele. So, if we used the symbols
we've used all throughout the course up until this
point to represent dominate and recessive, the regular CCR5
allele would be dominant, or the plus symbol.
And the CCR5 delta 32 would be recessive, or
the minus symbol. And the reason is because
the dominant CCR5 allele masks the effect of the
recessive CCR5 delta 32 allele. As long as
you have one of these dominant alleles here, then
HIV is going to be able to latch on and
infect the T-cell. You must be homozygous recessive before
you have no protein available on the surface
of T-cells for HIV to latch onto and affect.